alright guys bangbang I'm here with
Helen we got a lot to talk about because
you work on what I think is one of the
most important things in crypto but
nobody ever talks about it so you are
here all the way from China thank you
for coming it's my great pleasure
good luck most people don't come and
tell me that it's their pleasure to be
here usually my pleasure let's start
with your background before we get into
the work with finance because you've
been working on kind of philanthropic
efforts for a long time right yes all
right what uh where were you born first
I was born in northeast of China
northeast yeah I was in China and - I
was 17 and I left a China - went to
England to get educated I I was I'm a
trained actuary an actuary actually
solve the most boring job you know art
it's important though for like insurance
right yes I used to be the chief actuary
for Zurich Financial Services in China
really yeah after 10 years working in
the city of London
okay what was the biggest difference
between China and England when when you
went Wow um was funny I remember when
England in 1995 in 1995 yes and at that
time there are two things number one I
went to Chinatown nobody speaks Mandarin
in Chinatown they all speak Cantonese
which is a dark dialogue in people
speaking in Hong Kong and then when I
left London in 2000 in 2005 okay um if
you go to like louis vuitton chanel at
least there's a stuff speaks mandarin
whoa hornacek so when you got there in
1995 Chinatown everyone spoke Cantonese
but they didn't speak Mandarin exactly
very few men during customers Europe and
then the time I left do you know like 12
years later you know if you go to the
big department store everyone speaks
Mandarin there's at least a staff speaks
Chinese speaks
during that means actually the traffic
there's customers traffic yeah can if I
speak Mandarin you speak Cantonese can
we understand each other not really not
really so it's a pretty different
dialect exactly Wow so I think my
generation is a very interesting
generation in China we witness the huge
economic growth the year I was born in
China the GDP per capita in 1978 is only
154 US dollars okay which is less than
one-third of the sub-sahara Africa
countries so the year I was born in
Chinese pretty true yeah it's very poor
China and then in my generation I
witness six hundred eighty million
people has been lifted out the
international poverty line in China
according to World Bank the number of
people living under the international
poverty line in China and under the
inter port under the international
poverty line in the world since 1962
today didn't decline if I exclude the
six hundred eighty million people in
China really how biggest that's since
you want to understand China so I think
China in the last centuries make made
the huge the biggest development effort
in the world in terms of poverty
reduction yeah and so what have they
done to do poverty reduction in China
what are their four efforts yeah I think
this is a great question I think job
creation it is the key for poverty
reduction if they are looking at what
even like a much bigger level from 1960
to 2008 globally there's about 200
developing economies but in the period I
just mentioned there's only actually two
economies moved from low income status
to high income status that is South
Korea and Taiwan China likely to be the
third one by 2025 out of those 200
developing economies only 30 of them
moved from middle income status to high
income status out of those 13 eight of
the Maggi Europe the orange in the GDP
kappa a higher so the cat is smaller
smaller so the other five are the Asia
four Tigers
plus Japan it was a common consensus in
the world post second war in the 1960s
Africa has a much better chance for
economic transformation a
is a hopeless continent but the reality
our human history is the opposite I
think one of the biggest thing is
development models because Africa has
been followed in a way the Western eight
driven development models but in that in
Asia they were actually the country who
had a huge chunks for economic
transformation they will really take
they took the golden opportunity in the
60s and 80s theory industrialization
relocation they were able to capture
that golden opportunity created millions
of jobs for people in the bottom of the
pyramid and that is the chance that of
those countries across the rich
basically it's how do you give people
opportunity when you give them
opportunity they end up getting income
when they have income then they can get
above that poverty line because they're
actually kind of working for income
which leads to higher means of living
rather than go some of the other routes
that other countries have gone where
it's more of kind of socialist and let's
just hand money to everybody this will
actually solve some of the problem I
think that's correct also very
importantly I really believing the
empower the bottom the part of the
pyramid
I think descent this is why I'm soaking
on the decentralized idea for the
corruption technology because if I'm
looking you know like for example in
Africa the traditional model you know
maybe you sell oil who can benefit it
the top five percent of the people and
then when the money when they're sitting
there in their bank account maybe
insulin that how about the middle layer
and the bottom layer that is the problem
but if you are looking at Asia
development model when they work on
industrialization the workers get paid
when they get paid they go to spend in
the restaurant and then they spend go to
the cinema the whole economy got
actually empowered so I think the
empowering the bottom layer it's very
powerful to to kind of holy Kaname
transformation instead just having the
top 1% people getting rich got it and so
when you think about kind of
philanthropic efforts around the world
you've spent a lot of time in Africa
maybe talk about how your experience
there and
prior rules you had before you came over
to buy Nance and then we can talk about
what you guys are dealing with by Nance
sure the reason actually moved me from
financial sector actually to to
development I did my executive and be
from he said in a during that cause I
had a leadership development on my first
day my coach asked me Helen what kind of
leader you want to be I said before I
want to become a leader I want some true
happiness you know for myself and
talking about my personal background I
think my general I was born in he now
sees China
my definition of purpose before I was 30
is to become a good daughter which is to
a good daughter a good daughter which is
to study well go to a good college and
then go to a big company climb the
corporate ladder I did the executive
that I made my parents very happy but an
angel of surgery I asked myself I'm
actually have helped myself not really
that kind of happiness have to be inside
so that's the question I actually asked
my coach I want true happiness he told
me something he said Helen in order to
achieve that true happiness you need
four pillars in life you need the past
future achievement and purpose very
important the past future achievement
achievement and purpose and purpose okay
and then purpose is something a goal
much bigger than yourself or go you can
pursue for the rest of your life that's
actually something making your personal
happiness and actually I did a lot of
internal thinking during my leadership
years journey with my coach that's
actually I realized you know pursuing
just personal gain in the financial
sector that didn't really make me the
true happiness which actually I left the
financial sector who went into Africa
really pursuing that bigger goal and I
was really glad I find a kind of bigger
purpose because why I saw those poor
girls in Africa during my first trip
down there which remind my childhood and
then but then I witnessed this I'm a
beneficiary of the Asia's economic
transformation something really I
realized I could becoming a new
revolution to helping them to change
their face that make me to happiness
this is actually the work I've done in
the past ten years in Africa which is
bringing what I
from Asia the development model
industrialization the model who helped
China Asia for tiger development the job
creation that kind of model to
supporting Africa
so that's actually the the things before
I joined bina's but then in 2015 I was
becoming a young global leader of what
Economic Forum's so I was being exposed
to the fourth Industrial Revolution
which make me think you know every
generation have every generations to
take the multi-pin pushing is the second
industrialization model bring that model
to africa but then let's look at the
third Industrial Revolution which is
internet-based what happened in the
world yes
you know us in China we're celebrating
the technological advancement but if
you're looking at a bigger picture 1% of
the population actually is holding 90%
of the global wealth the word didn't
become a better place so now where are
the generation at the beginning to
trying to shape the fourth Industrial
Revolution I think it's very important
we need to think it's not just about
technological advancement for the richer
people we need to think how to make the
world a better place not for our
generation for our future generation so
this is something I truly believe you
know technology should serve people and
should create values and one of the
thing I think the beauty of blockchain
crypto is actually providing a newer
tool to empower the bottom billion
that's one of the reason we set up the
bynars charity foundation we want to use
the technology not just making the rich
people more richer actually is to make
the word an even better place and that's
what we also started our pilot year
Africa you know to using the technology
to empower them so before we get into
kind of what you guys are doing right
now you spent a lot of time in the
finance sector you then came over to the
philanthropic area one of the questions
I have is you keep using the word
development right which is obviously a
different word than charity or film
philanthropy why the focus on that
specific word like what is the
importance of that word versus you know
charity or philanthropy
yeah you know in my view 9
sixty-two Liuzhou talked about in the
social country introduced the concept of
social contract and he said you know we
all perform free but everywhere we we
are in changed if you are looking at
since then the human history actually is
a history of human beings trying to
search for good society whether is a
capitalist or communist or whatever
we're all trying to serve a form of a
good society to get rid of the chains
but if we are looking at that whatever
the system we created it's always
controlled by human beings you know and
human beings because you cannot get rid
of the human nature you know so people
take a loophole you know in the system
so I think in this year with the first
Industrial Revolution it's the first
time in human history actually we have
technology have to set up a certain
discipline to combine with you know
human system we can try to build up a
new system to making a good society and
this is something what I call
development because with human beings
you know where are you know with keeping
your status trying to search him for
good society I think we're still in that
stage and I think with our generation
the beauty we have something very
powerful
you know it's not just a political
regime something called technology we
can blended this to becoming a wind to
trying to think about good society for
sure and I guess the issues in Africa
across all of the different countries in
Africa where do you guys see like the
biggest problems right so not so much
like what are the issues on the ground
that need to be solved but more in in
kind of the philanthropic and charity
activities right one of the things that
has always struck me as pretty crazy is
when somebody makes a donation to a
charity whether it's the United States
or elsewhere let's say I give $100
there's now organizations that have been
set up to measure how much of that
hundred dollars actually reaches the end
person right and I think you guys are
going after solving this plus talk about
the problem first likely is it $50 for
every $100 is it
20 dollars like what do you guys see in
terms of how efficient some of these
charities aren't actually making an
impact
okay currently if I give you a number
we'll be around 20% a 20% go into
actually that and benefit so every
hundred dollars I donate only twenty
dollars actually goes to where I wanted
it to go you know weigh it directly but
then there's a lot of indirect costs
occurred so but that's all
actually for good charity organization
but there's also a lot of charity
organization you have no idea so this is
something maybe to further understand
the problem maybe I asked you a question
Anthony how much did you donate roughly
per year ten years ago well ten years
ago I was 21 years old so like nearly
nothing okay right I may be a parents
generation how much he donate yeah I
actually don't know that's a great
question right kind of a generation
above me I'm not really sure but I think
a lot of the donations in the United
States I well it depends on how you
categorize donation I bet you that that
generation the largest line item in
terms of contributions right would be to
their church yeah ten percent tithing is
very popular in a number of Christian
religions etc I bet you that's probably
the largest donation that they made in
in terms of everything that they gave to
and then obviously there's things like
the Red Cross and you know some of those
organizations but they're not really
sure what the number it would be oh yeah
do you know the answer I don't know the
answer but I see a trend but okay what's
happened
the trendy if I ask myself would my
children donated the same way like my
grandparents I think completely not oh
they would donate in a different way
yeah or will they donate more or less
you think I want them to done I think I
wish them to donate more that's actually
one of the thing the work we're doing
now we won't we encourage our future
than generation you know to have to I
think they also have more privilege you
know to help the others so but currently
I think the system we've got the
donation system
is still actually the same as 30 years
back so there should be a new system you
know also for the newer generation which
they believe we want to encourage them
and we talked about actually you talked
about you said very good you talk about
currently the system there's a lack of
trust you give it to an intermediate but
you have no control in Demeter's doing
sometimes if you let's say you give you
know a tarnation collect a million you
know like to support of project but
maybe they pay half million you know on
the administration fee you need to pay
heavy money for PwC to audit you know to
produce the auditor account is that
right I'm not saying actually they there
is corruption to have the 80% you know
in their pocket but there's various
costs you know you introduce actually
the money didn't really go into the end
beneficiary but I think today based
technology we can reduce the middle cost
and they're having more benefit to the
end beneficiary that's actually the work
I I do and actually that's what we truly
believe something we should actually
build for our generation they can trust
and they can relate there should be more
direct and this is even also thinking
about a bigger perspective I think
internet allowed free transfer of
information block tree itself in the
next 10 20 years
you should allow free transfer of value
that means everywhere you know like the
internet 10 years ago you cannot think
if I'm a pool girl in Africa I have no
idea you know like what Anthony is
talking about in this part of the world
at this type of this internet you can
achieve that and the value transfer I
think in the future we should see that
exactly the same if you want to transfer
somebody in a small village you know
yeah Africa you should do that
immediately yeah out barrier what what
you're talking about is basically that
there was this huge barrier in terms of
exchanging information right so the
printing press was one of the big kind
of inflection points of sharing of
information that obviously the invention
of the internet was another big
inflection point so there's been a
reduction in
kind of friction or obstacles of
exchanging information for a long time
when it came to value the internet
helped a little bit right there there's
some inflection point there and that's
great
blockchain technology as you're
describing is probably going to be
another inflection point in hindsight
etc but when it comes to charities
development philanthropic efforts
there's two really big pieces one is the
cost of actually transferring the value
but two is also the transparency right
the people who want to give but don't
have the confidence that it's actually
going to go to what they want you guys
are helping to solve that so let's talk
a little bit about finance charity about
two years ago you came over and started
working with finance why did you do that
right by Nantz was relatively unproven I
think right it was kind of a fast
growing company sees these obviously I
think very kind of innovative and a lot
of people have rally behind him but why
did you want to come over and work in
encrypt oh and by night specifically
yeah I know Cece actually for more than
10 years of our friends oh really yeah
okay even before - he was on the Forbes
magazine magazine in the front cover of
Forbes magazine on February 2018 and we
had a lunch actually together around
March at that time and then during lunch
we actually didn't talk about you know
like the company first we talk about
purpose you know he's after thinking
about the 4cc after he's being on the
front page of folks he also thinking
about this question so that's one of the
thing I shared with him is also my
personal journey
yeah Africa and also the way I've been
searching my purpose so actually I think
make him a lot of thinking so he asked
me a question he said Helen what do you
think the future of the purpose of
openness at that time I said from
success to significant I think I
eventually you know the goal actually
for finance during that conversation I
also understand Mobile's easy basically
he truly believed the technology itself
should make a much bigger impact in our
human history this actually the purpose
and then in order to do that and that's
why we came into a conversation he said
after that
he said Helen why don't I set up a -
charity
Caillou help me to hide it up this
foundation I didn't said yes at that
time you did not say yes I said I said
cz I said that's what you and me maybe
fingers right to do but that's not
enough we should hear from the end
beneficia the people we want help would
they welcome to do what we want to do so
in the following months I made some
arrangement so you may I took Seiji to
Africa and then I introduced I took him
to Togo and then to Uganda in Uganda we
met the President of Uganda he was 74
years old okay no clearly he's not
rationally to show you so you see Z and
the President of Uganda yeah and yes 74
years old you guys are there to talk
about blockchain encrypted exactly how'd
that go
what's very fascinating which actually
I've had a lot of admiration to the
president clearly he does a technology
that that much so we talk about some
fundamental things we talk about
he's old time the patter time you know
like he had changed his cow actually for
some food and then we talk about why we
need US Dollars and then we talk about
actually what's the fundamental law
actually for crypto and there are those
kind of very basic conversation you know
what happened the president become very
quiet for a few minutes and he look at a
city and me he said listen my friend
today for African countries we have a
choice wherever choice to determine our
development path we also have a choice
to choose our partners today I choose
you to to becoming our partners to come
here to work with us in this what you
called force Industrial Revolution
I think we should not become followers
anymore we want to becoming leaders
that's why we choose you to work with us
to develop something to work for us so
this is the president said you know of
some very good very good you know that's
he's 74 years old
this actually after that conversation I
said to si si si si si now I'm taking
your offer I'm going to hide the
foundation that's actually how
everything started that's awesome yeah
and actually why first hide up the
foundation what I thought you know this
finance limited resource but still quite
powerful in the crypto industry we
should empower the existing initiatives
so we actually had a calling of the
industry I want to support some existing
crypto industry you know we've got
actually can't with be about more than
hundred you know companies who are doing
a crypto charity who contact us was
actually a little bit PTY look at them a
hundred companies in detail that was two
years ago about 50% of them are not
genuine they're just using you know like
the charity philanthropy you know had
but you need we're looking deeper on the
business model they're actually working
for their personal gain and the other
fifty percent I think it's a very early
stage of development that's one of the
reason we came to the idea instead you
know just you know giving the money away
we need to do something and today we two
years ago we realize what is really
missing it's not just people shouting
about doing good things it's really
about the last mile solutions you need
to do something concretely on the ground
you know at the last mile proving it
works and then this is something
actually we focused in the past one year
my setup team actually they have been
stationed in Africa for a year
developing this transparent charity
platform making charge a donation
transparent and empowering the end
beneficiary with script or ID allowing
for free transform value I think this is
something I'm really proud of you know
for the industry we demonstrate
something in the last mile it actually
value creation for crypto on the ground
is quicker cheaper because looking at a
bigger perspective what groups will do I
know Anthony you believe crypto going to
replace Fiat my view is actually in the
coming few years crypt
and least should play a very important
complementary to Fiat and then you order
to look deeper of that concept if I'm
looking at global population currently
the bottom billion people that being
excluded in the existing financial
industry Citibank them serve people you
know for the bottom billion people you
know a Bank of China don't serve those
people and those people doesn't mean
those people don't have right being
served if I'm making the world better
place we need somebody need to consider
them and this is actually when we give
the crypto wallet yeah Africa through
the charity donation system we empower
them with something like a bank account
allowing doing value transfer and I
think this is also something I think for
the industry we should consider it's not
just making some one of the 1% of the
crypto industry user richer it was
thinking about how to have the mass
adoption for crypto users and I think
the bottom billion people is a people in
need and we want to serve them yeah part
of this to me is you can go try to
convince people in the United States to
use crypto every single day but the US
dollar and the US financial system work
pretty well right like you can go get
money of the ATM you can go swipe your
car and pay for something all of those
things you can get paid in a bank
account etc you can buy assets you know
whatever it is but then there's a whole
group of people in the world a very
material percentage of the population
that don't have access to a bank account
they don't have access to any sort of
financial services etc so rather than go
target let's get people who the system
you know pretty much works for them to
switch over that's a pretty hard and
tall task instead let's go serve people
who they don't have access to any of
this stuff and now with just an internet
connection or a mobile device they now
can get all of the services and value
that kind of the Western or developed
role has had for a long time and you
guys are doing it in a very unique way
by it sounds like first giving people
crypto wallets right who can now receive
funds and gets them kind of on-boarded
to one crypto but also to to financial
services in general absolute
and if you ask me you know my bigger
vision I think today data is the new
currency and then how to define
individuals wealth you know currently
you and me we go to Facebook but
actually Facebook get out the item at
heisman free you know using our data I
think eventually we should own our own
data and we should actually have benefit
on that and in order for us to leverage
that to having uh you know a crypto ID
you know to allow the first basic
infrastructure for value transfer but on
top of it in the coming years there
should be more things to develop how we
can actually making our data becoming
our assets and then we can actually
exchanging our assets with the others
through the system there's more things
to develop so my view is today
blockchain still is like 20 years ago
one you are meeting about internet you
we would never imagine today's iPhone
right but I think 20 years later
blockchain will take a lot of new forms
we cannot we with today we cannot
imagine so today still technology
looking for application so we would call
ourselves still industry shapers trying
to use the basic element of the
technology which is transparent
trackable to solve some simple problem
but on it we build have the main most
important basic infrastructure for the
system and keep trying
yeah what is the different things that
today people can work with financial
charity to contribute to right so my
understanding is that you guys have set
up infrastructure but if the structure
can kind of be pointed at different use
cases so one can be let's go try to
solve hunger in certain countries and
there's about nine other things what are
those other nine things that you guys
are helping people to donate towards
various places you know there's hunger
that was also refugee project and we
also have kinds of project actually
motor so there's a lot of you so the
whole idea about charity foundation I
want to talk about three things number
one first you can Pervis
- with Nasdaq Nasdaq never committed to
give all their listing fees do you know
what's their listing fees for that's
that no idea
so for bina's all the listing fees CZ
committed all the listing fees actually
is going to be a hundred percent
transparent okay so this is important
people to understand yeah with crypto
exchange it's just like in traditional
exchange there's a listing fee yes that
listing fee basically is an amount of
money that company pay company pays to
get their token or their stock listed on
whatever exchange they're trying to do
yes CZ and by Nantz have committed that
100% of all of those listing fees will
be put into the finance charity and
donated to the various efforts that you
guys are pursuing exactly
so because first we talked about it's
all about the wells pyramid globally the
biggest problem today is 1% of people
holding 90% of the global wells how weak
i have actually more wells to be more
universally distributed your transparent
debate so as a company's level i think
if you compare you know finance with
Nasdaq we are making the initiative we
are encouraging we think even though
you're at the early stage of development
with the new generation you don't need
to become super rich become Bill Gates
to support people at this stage you can
unbind us our company while doing that
and then in this I think we want to
encourage the whole crypto industry you
know the company you know following this
footstep to do this and secondly if you
are looking at actually the way the
charity operate is the only charity
today actually we charge 0 the
ministration fee we talked about early
on if you donate hundred dollars to
something you know maybe eighty percent
pasted into the administration fees not
because those people are bad or
corruption but those are actually costs
today in our charity we say hundred
percent of your donation going into an
beneficiary which has zero
administration fee and for this
everything is not just by word of me
saying it everything's unblocking is the
untrackable you can track actually
whether your money went into the and
beneficiaries or counter actually went
into somewhere in the middle so right
now you guys only accept donation
in crypto you're working on fiat right
but right now I can donate to buy nan
charity in crypto when I make that
donation 100% of the operations and
administrative costs are covered by by
Nance right so my hundred dollars in
Bitcoin or B&B or whatever it is goes
directly to those on the receiving end
of that development worker that that
philanthropic work and like you said I
can actually track it transparently on a
blockchain right so I can see exactly
where my money's going and I know that
that cause that I'm donating to is the
actual beneficiary exactly and this is
something in the past when you say you
trust certain names
that's your trust that organization our
person today basically I'm saying you'll
hear what Helen says but you don't have
to trust me you trust the system and try
to some technology don't lie and this is
what I said earlier where entry your
stage you know Trust is built our
blended of human and also a technology
this is the beauty yeah but it's not
just trust in the system as much as it's
having confidence in this system because
I can verify the system advise the
verification is what builds that
ultimate trust but they're really just
confidence and what's happening is I can
see it sure and actually I have also a
few questions for you and her how long
have you be in the industry
so we talked about it before and it says
15 beginning 2016 so was that four years
now something like that
four years okay and you know um you were
born in the 80s right I was born in 1988
98
you know you represent your generation
you know like yes I think is the most
powerful generation you know in the you
know for the world now so what you truly
believe since you are in the blockchain
industry what do you see the purpose
actually for plowshare and also for your
generation
yeah in my whole thesis here is just
people are gonna trust the machines and
software over other humans right there's
a whole bunch of reasons why that
happens but ultimately when you do that
it has a pretty profound impact on the
world right and the biggest one being
eventually you choose a currency that is
a fully transparent
monetary policy that can be verified
right so I think Bitcoin eventually
becomes the global reserve currency but
then if you look at how do you apply
these the really automated triple entry
accounting system tri triple entry
accounting is I think highly overlooked
in the space but people who can
understand that triple entry accounting
brings transparency and it brings kind
of that ability to verify if you can do
it an automated fashion Michael
blockchain does and you overlay it on
pretty much every industry there's
massive disruption because what you go
from is hey I have a trusted brand to my
customer can now verify and I think that
that's a sounds like somewhat of a
nuance point but it can be quite
powerful when it's actually put into
practice and we're seeing that happen
and a number of industries already today
fantastic and what do you see the
biggest challenge for crypto right now
time time just takes time yeah because
every day somebody new learns about it
somebody new starts using it somebody
new you know receives crypto somebody
tells their friend about crypto etc and
if you go back over the last 11 years
there's been kind of a continued
education and adoption of both Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies or products
that are built on top of or supporting
various block chains etc and so this
with time comes adoption right and I
think it's because it's pretty obviously
the technology works the technology has
value but that time just has to pass and
humans hate that answer right because we
all want to go do something today that's
gonna solve the problem but it's just a
timed game so I think when people kind
of realize that it's okay just chill out
right like keep doing what you're doing
right it's all important work but just
takes time right and so everyone have
some more patience and will be it will
be good to go
you think me I think now right now
technology we're still at a technology
curve for the technology is early
adopters I think and then the next
biggest movie we need to reach to early
majority that means roughly about 10
percent of the global population have to
use the technology and turn delay I
think the crypto users are roughly about
2% of the global population so how to
make that 8 percent jump I
is the biggest challenge that's why 5x
yes and that's why I think that 5x is
not just in the middle class globally
that's why I think actually the bottom
layer that's actually what I said where
crypto can play a very important
complementary in the existing system if
I were able to you know through the
transparent system you know to empower
the bottom billion I think actually the
technology is definitely going to stay
and that's everybody is looking for now
you know for the non crypto user that
looking for truly values in there so
that's something I would really
encourage you know more people come into
working the space it the way I think
about it is like a unit of improvement
in quality of life right active and so
if you look at like the richest people
in the world if you met if you could
somehow measure like the unit of
improvement of quality of life bitcoin
B&B by Nance crypto blockchain all that
stuff it has some impact but it is on a
percentage basis much much lower then
let's say the bottom billion people in
the world in terms of wealth it can have
a very material impact on their life and
so it's almost like who is it more
important for right it's actually more
important for the people have nothing
right or very little today rather than
people who have a lot because you're
essentially it's kind of like when a
start-up says hey we grew 5,000 percent
month-over-month and you're like okay
but you started with one user right and
then you improve 5,000 percent well
that's much harder or that's much easier
to do then let's say you know Google
who's got hundreds of millions of users
to do 5,000% and so I think that that
improvement in the quality of life is
really important but also it's it's
almost like if you can affect a human's
life where you want to go to the highest
impact area right and that bottom
billion is obviously a place where you
can do that we were talking before the
podcast I want to make sure that we
cover it also around this idea of crypto
you know systematically helping a lot of
the issues in the world versus
philanthropy and development work
kind of working at the micro-level how
do you think about the charitable work
that you guys do in terms of solving
macro problems versus more solving the
micro problems
I said shame we didn't we're not able to
show a video actually we just did a
video you know live video you know in
Africa to shooting under actually impact
you know we've actually achieved you
know through our charity project you
know today's like the year end video ya
Yin 2019 video where we showed it
actually in Miami
two days later I think when you really
this is something very powerful for me
is one my team are working in Africa on
the ground you know working with the
people you understand what they truly
need and that's what I always say the
last mile solution is really impacting
them we started with a lunch project and
actually we didn't have any thoughts
what's the next part actually they come
to tell us what they need for example we
have a group of girls on the ground come
to our team saying you know what they've
never use you know tampons
you know sanitary pads in their lifetime
and then a lot of girls you know they
had a lifetime issues when they grew up
so the so that's why we initiated that
what we call the pink
caro-kann project you know pink care
token from the first stable point for
the industry with because people say hey
you know like maybe the fluctuation
white donate you know my money so we
introduced actually a stable coin
basically each pink care token represent
to supporting one girls one year's
supply you know of Senator pass and you
can actually Tony is that just how much
is that in like US dollar charge roughly
around four dollars so four dollars or
four dollars you give you support one
girls one year's sanitary pass that's
pretty crazy yeah so basically we say
hey you know for me is think what we
don't need to talk about dollars we just
need to thinking about you know I won
to support a hundred people you know
that's how much I need and you give that
stable you just buy you know hundred
stable tokens and you actually all the
tokens go to and beneficials you know a
counter from their account to the
suppliers and then we have a system to
tracking everything so this is something
we were and in this project we have more
than 46 crypto companies participated
they are saying hey you know as a
company we want to fulfill our
responsibilities each company at least
support more than one hundred and
thousands girls you know in this so this
is something we want people when people
donate and support they can actually
point-to-point
support and they're also the same thing
with our land project we have the
company saying hey I want to I want to
just pick a school you know give me a
school year Africa and how many peoples
there we just committed for my company
I'm going to be a hundred percent
support in the next five years
supporting for all the school kids in
here and everything's transparent and
how much for like the school supplies
and things like this about 30,000 US
dollar equivalent per year to support
for the land project you know that
thirty thirty thousand dollars per year
would support how many kids about around
five hundred five hundred kids they get
lunch for a year yes you know with how I
think education is very important but
you know when you're on the ground while
we're supporting lunch a lot of children
they go to the classroom with empty
stomach they're not even focusing on the
teachers and then so this is something
you know the school are saying Helen you
you are here to help us how you first
support us on the most basic
humanitarian support so those are the
things we test it down but I think the
most important thing as I said eat
whatever the project is different kind
of forms the thing we want to
demonstrate is the peer to peer
transparent transfer and actually today
wherever you are your small areas rural
village in Africa you've never been to
you can actually point to points about
that today maybe stretch the charge but
then when we have a better
ss value system you can actually
transfer values globally this is
something we truly believe that's how
crypto you know should actually create
truly values globally what do you think
is twenty years from now what do you
think that financed charity looks like
I'm pretty sure there will be a lot of
new applications first of all I think
there I want to be for the organization
itself I want to empower more younger
people to lead it so today you know you
- we call ourself nobody is a manager
we're all leaders so for me it's the
holy centralized idea how to empower the
new generation - taking it as a platform
to do us - making the best use of
themselves so I want to encourage more
and engineers tech people coming to the
platform thinking about how they can
achieve their personal goals and then at
the same time you know I'm pretty sure a
lot of you know beneficiary is going to
be benefited I think the word should
become a better place for my sense
generation come here and that's why we
call ourselves an industry shapers the
work we are doing probably not going to
be the same 20 years later we'll take
another very different forms but I I
want to look back - very proud you know
during this process we didn't just sit
there and wait we try things somethings
successful people keep trying better
things something maybe fail but we learn
from that
and we make the progress this is about
you know like how to best leverage every
minute of our time isn't it Anthony yeah
for sure what um what is your pitch to
people right when you meet somebody and
you say hey this is what I work on day
to day here's the impact we can have
there's a lot of people were gonna
listen to this what's kind of your pitch
to them as to why they should
participate the finance charity versus
somebody else I would use the word
actually Steve Jobs once said he said
I'm poking Steve Jobs very smart with
the tech audience he said
now Siri wants to yell at me okay go
ahead sure he said innovation
distinguish series yelling at me now
guys we're good alright go ahead
he said innovation distinguished leaders
and followers I think actually today I
want to encourage more people to use the
innovation you know to define themselves
not just followers
being leaders in the industry to keep
trying so this is something I would
really pitch to people as I don't think
frankly I don't think what I did today
is hundred percent perfect but I went on
because this is the early stage of the
technology as I said technology's still
looking for application but I'm very
proud of the work we're doing is we
actually never stop trying and then
we're really focusing on the last miles
working Vista and beneficiaries to
understand what they need what they want
it's not just that what I want what I
need so I would encourage more people
actually to join our project and also
even inviting them to Africa and to some
you know wait this year we want to
actually also expand our project into
the u.s. we want to have more partners
you know also to work with us to test on
the in the existing system what we've
got how they can help us to go to the
next stage together so we're very open
and I think the system we've built it up
we eventually I want to make it like an
open system everybody can use and
everybody you know can benefit for sure
at the age of 30 you said that you
started to think about purpose and
that's pretty young I think actually for
most people to think about that what um
this is a little dark question but but
uh it tells me a lot about somebody the
day you die when people say you know
whoops sorry she's dead but they say but
the world was better off because she was
here she did X right what you're
remembered for what is that X I think uh
I that's a very very good question
I don't want to waste every single
minute of my time that's what actually
I've been doing why I started who's
thinking about purpose but there are lot
of thing I did even though being you
know a point about you and in the past
in the past you know being my work in
Africa as the UN Goodwill Ambassador I
know that was never my goal my goal is
actually following my heart and telling
you a story which actually deep today
still remember I went to Africa in 2011
what country Ethiopia prior that
actually I spend a year in Switzerland
so from Switzerland to go to Ethiopia
pretty big difference huh yeah and then
I stayed you know at 2011 there's only
one five-star hotel Ethiopia called
Sheraton soif the charity you can
imagine but it has a huge garden full of
roses so two days after I woke her I
looked around sitting after dinner I was
digesting my food so I was walking along
the garden and then suddenly hears some
music and then which took me to the back
of the hotel there's a park called
office spa I went to that part I looked
around 2011 I didn't see any African
people you know like having drinks
enjoying food it's all foreigners from
Europe us and also Asia which remind me
a true story that was a thirty years
back you know why was you know seven
years old that was that was early 80s my
it was my birthday my father wanted to
give me a treat okay China so he took me
to the capital which is Beijing at that
time can you imagine today at that time
there's only well five-star hotel in
Beijing called Beijing hotel my father
took me to the reception and he asked
the receptionist how much he is a polite
because he want the family to get
familiar at a trade the reception tone
my father hundred dollars that was in
the early eighties thinking about the
GDP I mentioned the you know at that
time China at that time my father
immediately said that is too expensive
we cannot afford it so he was taking me
away from the beautiful five-star hotel
Beijing hotel
the moment I was away from their hotel
as a little girl I turned my head back
I look at Lobby I didn't see Chinese
people you know asked us I see all the
my foreigners dressing very well at that
moment I thought that is a word does not
belong to me that he's a word will never
belong to me but then my life changed
dramatically you know I went to England
at age of 17 and become you know senior
VP of globalization to be honest I don't
think that is something about how good I
am because actually I would in a part of
the world the countries find the right
development path so the moment I was in
Sheridan hotel you know in 2011 he Theo
Pia what went through my mind is outside
the big gate of Sheraton there must be a
lot of young girls thinking exactly like
me thirty years back in their mind
inside a big gate of Sheraton full of
roses is a word does not belong to them
it's a word of you never belong to them
what they don't know is unless their
country can find the right path of
development their life will change
dramatically so since then I would call
myself as an industry shaper trying to
help Africa shaping the job creation
through industrialization now as a newer
generation I'm trying to see what we can
do in the fourth Industrial Revolution
you seemed actually a higher level to
thinking about helping those country to
find the right path of development
because I truly believe that is a way to
change some generations it's just like
my life being transformed
you know without kind of development
past change in China today I would be
that poor girl you know outside the big
gate you know of a hotel thinking about
that word will never belong to me and I
think in 20 years later I hope you're a
lot of poo places a lot of girl are also
proud you know their life can be changed
and I think today the blockchain
technology and crypto is a powerful tool
you know we should we should use it well
you know make the world a better place
and I think there's two components to
this right so one is
there's the macro issues and then
there's the micro issues the micro
issues are the girl who needs the
sanitary pads right the child who needs
lunch for a year etc and so we can use
donations right where those who have
something can give to those who don't
have something and we can make their
lives better right and kind of it's um
it's a way to reduce pain it's a way to
reduce poverty to some degree right it's
a way to kind of address the problem and
that is where I think - charity is
playing a fantastic role of show hey
look these blockchains can actually show
full transparency we can increase the
efficiency of your dollars and the
impact of your dollars with these new
systems right and so it's incredibly
commendable the problem that the micro
solutions don't bring is there's still
the macro problem right there's still
people in poverty there's still all
these issues and that's where I think
you know my personal view is that
something like Bitcoin can come in and
actually have a macro impact because
what it does is it rewires the whole
system right the thing that I spend a
lot of time talking to younger kids
right usually kind of 25 and younger and
they'll DM me on Twitter or send me an
email and always asking you know like
what should I do with my life all my
stuff they're good questions but what I
realized is they don't understand that
the deck is stacked against them right
they don't understand that unless they
do very specific things on the investing
front if they just continue to earn
income and leave it in Fiat inflation
and all these issues it's just it's
really hard to get ahead right that the
deck is stacked against them and so I
think that by rewiring that system what
you get is less income inequality which
is a systemic solution but before that
happens right that's gonna take a very
very long time we need to have highly
transparent you know kind of nonprofit
organizations that are solving those
micro issues and saying to the person
look you don't have 30 years to wait
around for a macro solution right you -
you're hungry today how do we help you
today and so I think the work you guys
are doing is super-important and you
know I'm just personally thankful
anything a lot of other people are super
excited you guys are doing this thank
so much engineer you know I told you to
agree what you just said I think this
whole crypto development is going to be
a motion of things and people playing
different role and in this battle
actually for the patent and charity we
decided our batter is going to be coming
the last mile solutions you know to
really prove being something really
concrete on the ground creating the
value and we believe very successful in
success very demonstrate is actually
work it's actually you can have the big
snowboarding effect and today you know
be on our show I really appreciate you
know people like you to spreading the
good things about the industry to
encouraging more people to continue the
revolution you know to making it into
the next level so it's my great pleasure
to be here to talking to you today for
sure I usually say the virus is
spreading talking about Bitcoin but
today the charity virus is spreading yes
where can people find you online and
also where can they find out more
information about binary arity I you
just go to our website you can find
actually you can donate directly and
then you you you can also find me in
linking on LinkedIn yeah okay
and before I let you go I'll let you ask
me one question but we got to talk about
aliens you believe in aliens or no why
not well I don't know do you you think
they're real I think Nelson Mandela once
said it's always impossible and who is
that no one has come on this podcast and
invoked Nelson Mandela to answer the
only question but it is it's a good way
to view the world right alright what one
question do you have for me to end what
would you donate of course we'll talk
afterwards I got ideas Thank You Helen
is a professional because she came on
the podcast and got me to donate with
one question so you win but narrow that
I got some ideas and things that we can
do and I might even be able to get a
couple of companies that maybe aren't
donating yeah we can we can help explain
to them the importance of this work and
then see if we get them involved as well
thank you so much Antony absolutely
thank you so much for coming
my Creed pledge I get